I'd rather have someone poop all over me
or have my kid poop on an airplane or
have my kid pee on my head or poop my
pants then we covered in dead whale so
they can say that definition really
remarkable observation when I was 13 my
family took a cruise and at one of the
ports my parents thought it would be a
good idea to take the bus to one of the
further less populated beaches to spend
the day so far so good
lo and behold it was a nude beach now
it's getting really 13 it was my first
trip on our first time seeing a man
naked that can be startling because it's
also like you've got an extremity we
don't know about you know what can I
pause the story for one second we were
on a 4th of July
trip with another family and all of us
have girls except one of our friends has
a boy and his name is ace and ace likes
to be nude and he's three and a half my
kids do - of course everyone and
everyone else is a girl and his mom said
ace okay it's five o'clock can you just
at least put some underwear on and he
goes why no why and she goes we'll just
I don't know because you know everyone
else is a girl and just just put put
some underwear on he goes
oh because I have a penis and they just
had buds my parents didn't want to waste
the day trying to find a different Beach
efficient they told my brothers and I to
look at the ocean only of course being
13 years old and curious I couldn't help
but look at the old man walking along
the beach I asked my parents why the men
were wearing their wedding rings around
their penises that was the start of
their discussion of rings with my
brother and I I will never forget or
it's just a way to express yourself I
mean I've wearing people wear brings
that nude pictures you know you're gonna
go to a nude beach why couldn't you wear
a piece of jewelry my brother that just
turned one when went to Disney World for
the first time and I was 10 I was
sitting on the plane beside my mom and
my brother started screaming I thought
it was because his ears were popping but
it turned out he had the worst diarrhea
ever
it was everywhere on the seat on my mom
on my brother the flight attendant
brought us club soda to quote unquote
fixed the problem and a garbage bag and
paper towels they wouldn't let my mom
get up because the seatbelt light wasn't
off yet she made holes in the garbage
bag and tied it at his waist sat him on
her lap and waited diarrhea is robbed
this poor kid though I do not it must
have smelled my husband and I were on
our honeymoon I was on medication that
made stuff happen a lot faster than
you'd hope we were two blocks from our
rental flat when I told my husband that
I had to go to capital now we walked
home on icy sidewalks as quickly as my
butt allowed as soon as we unlocked the
front door I felt it I did everything I
could to clench but it came forth like
an explosion of hot lava I crunched down
saying it's happening it's happening
like I was in bridesmaids we got up and
I finished in the bathroom as my amazing
husband cleaned up my pants with his
hands I definitely wasn't how we
expected our honeymoon to go but you
can't deny that that's love that's a
beautiful story that's not a horror
story I went on a cruise with my grandma
she tried to scatter my great Grandpa's
ashes off the back of the book I ended
up rinsing my grandpa off about four
levels of the ship with a cup of water
when my great grandma died and we wanted
to scatter her ashes in the same way my
grandma hollowed out bread rolls put the
ashes inside to prevent the repeated
events
my family and I were on a vacation in
Egypt I felt sick all day so as soon as
we got to the tombs I ran into the
bathroom bypassing the lady who was
handing out the toilet paper I rushed
into the stall as my ass exploded on the
toilet I kept yelling for my sister to
get me toilet paper but apparently you
have to pay for each square in public
restrooms there she ended up spending
four dollars on toilet paper
two hours later after we finished our
tour and walked by the lobby I saw a
closed for maintenance sign on the
toilet I used my ass literally broke an
Egyptian national monument that'll teach
you to put some you know roll tissue in
your pocket oh one fourth of July
weekend we got stuck in standstill
traffic and my youngest brother who was
six at the time kept complaining that he
had to pay we couldn't pull over and my
dad gave him a Gatorade bottle to pee
into my brother's started peeing the
bottle just as the traffic started
moving a little bit the sudden movement
of the car jolted my brother from where
he was standing it was a minivan and he
dropped the bottle but didn't stop me
he literally peed all over the side of
my dad's head and the steering wheel my
mom's side of the family consists of
about 20 Irish people and we often hire
out hostels to ourselves for the
Christmas holidays one year we stayed by
the seaside and my uncle overheard in a
local pub that a dead whale had washed
up on the beach and that someone was
going to blow it up and get rid of it
obviously we wanted to see the spectacle
when we finally arrived there were bits
of dead whale everywhere with the worst
rotting smell I have experienced to this
day my mum decided to kick a piece of
whale blubber that was lying around
which exploded and splattered all over
me I was 11 years old
covered head-to-toe in dead whale that's
rough that is rough
that would be a hard look for me I'd
rather have someone poop all over me or
have my kid poop on an airplane or have
my kids be on my head or poop my pants
then we covered in dead whale they can
say that definitively remarkable
observation my family and I were
vacationing in the Caribbean and my
sister ended up stepping on sharp coral
this can be a difficulty to make it
worse there were no hospitals in the
area so two fishermen have cut it out of
her foot while my parents held her
screaming on our way to the car my dad
realized he locked the keys in the
we ended up having one of the locals
break into the car on the way back to
the hotel a category 2 hurricane hit
from demolished the island we got
shelter in a coffee shop but not before
I was hit with a flying sign with us to
say we have not been back to the
Caribbean we were able to film this
movie there were two times in the
hallway where people just were like I'm
out and I we called 9-1-1 nothing
missing yeah I'm gonna write that down
in the buzz